[Music]
the beauty of BS code is that it starts
out minimal it allows you to customise
it into a full-blown integrated
development environment I really like
the atom one dark syntax theme vs code
icons I have a bunch of custom workspace
settings and extensions that I just
couldn't live without but the problem is
that all these customizations are tied
to my local machine but fortunately a
company called coder just recently open
sourced a project called code server
that allows you to run vs code in the
cloud in today's video I'll show you how
to run your own instance of code server
on Google cloud platform and will
supercharge it with a tensor processing
unit which will give it access to a
massive amount of computing resources
for machine learning if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can find a
step-by-step breakdown of this video on
fire ship i/o let's start by taking a
look at coder this is a startup that has
taken BS code and made it available in
the browser this allows you to access
your IDE with all of its settings from
any machine even a cell phone or tablet
if you wanted to it also allows multiple
developers to collaborate on the same
project from the same editor and because
you consult host it you can attach an
unlimited amount of computing resources
to its back-end the easiest way to get
started is to just log into coder and it
will immediately bring you to this
instance of des code and the awesome
thing about this is that it feels just
like the vs code on your desktop so the
first thing I'll do is go to the
extensions and then install the atom one
dark-themed much better and if we open a
terminal session you can see that we
have access to the actual virtual
machine that's running this container it
doesn't come with no js' installed by
default so I'm going to the node version
manager repo and grabbing the install
command that installs node version
manager on the container then we can use
nvm to install node itself at this point
we could install angular or react and
start doing front-end development from
this virtual environment when developing
in the browser you might notice a small
amount of lag when saving files because
that has to happen remotely but when
you're actually writing code it should
feel just like you're working in the
desktop version of es code now coder
gives us a couple gigabytes of memory
and storage space but there's a good
chance you want to go beyond these
limits by hosting your own instance in
the cloud which you can do on AWS GCP
Azure or wherever you want we'll set up
bars on Google cloud and I want to show
you how to set it up for both front-end
development and also for machine
learning specifically with ten surface
start by going to the GCP console and
find that compute engine tab we'll
create our own virtual machine with some
customized settings keep in mind this
will accrue cost on GCP so make sure to
shut it down when you're done using it
and everything is billed to the second
so you only have to have your virtual
machine running when you're actually
using BS code in the cloud the smallest
possible instance is about $4.00 per
month but that's probably not going to
be quite enough to run vs code
comfortably it's recommended to start
with a standard instance with two CPU
cores and 7.5 gigabytes of memory that
will cost you about 6 cents per hour to
run or about $49 per month if you just
leave it running continuously I'm just
going to go with the recommended two CPU
cores here and then we're going to set
the operating system to run 2:16 point
o4 we're going to be accessing it on the
web so we'll make sure to allow HTTP and
HTTPS traffic go ahead and click create
and then you should see a green
checkmark when it's ready the next thing
we want to do is install code server
which is the open source project that
powers coder in order to do that we need
to get access to the command line of
this virtual machine as the
administrator you'll see this SSH button
next to your VM if you click that it
will give you several different options
for starting a terminal session the
easiest options to just run in cloud
shell which will bring up a command line
in the browser window from there we'll
go back to github to find the download
link for the latest release of code
server on linux next we'll use the W git
command which gets things from the web
on Linux along with this download URL
that will download code server to the
actual file system on this virtual
machine when that's done we'll go ahead
and unzip it using the Attar command
then we can CD into the unzip directory
and that contains the actual binary that
will run vs code in the browser we'll
prefix the command with sudo and then
point to the code server binary and then
add flag P to run it on port 80 that
should tell you that it's running on
localhost 80 and then noticed the
password in the middle you'll want to
make sure to copy that and then you can
link directly to your external IP from
the GCP console from there you'll want
to add port 80 to the end of that IP and
it'll give you a warning that this
connection is not private you can ignore
that warning by going down to advanced
and then proceed to the IP URL from
there it's going to ask you for a
password to access the IDE copy and
paste that in from the terminal output
and we now have our own version of the
SK
running on GCP it's going to look and
feel exactly like the demo that we
looked at earlier on coder comm but now
we have full control over the underlying
compute resources I've already gone
ahead and installed my preferred themes
and also node and angular I'm going to
generate a new angular app and then try
to serve it on this local machine
angular serves on port 4200 by default
and if we try to go to port 4200 on this
IP address you can see that the
connection is refused
that's because VMs on Google have a
firewall implemented by default if
you're doing front-end development
you'll probably want to adjust the
settings of the firewall which you can
do by going to the network details for
this VM there's a few different ways you
can do this for example you can just
change the default rule to allow a
higher range of ports but you have fine
grain control over how the firewall
works so if you want to create your own
firewall rule you can do one that
specifically allows port 4200 for
angular I'm setting mine up for the more
general port of 8080 and we just checked
the box for TCP and allow traffic to
that port it's also important to give it
a tag because you can use that tag to
apply it to specific VMs if we go ahead
and save this rule and then go back to
our VM details you'll see an option for
Network tags just enter the tag that you
use for your firewall rule and then you
should be good to go to allow traffic to
the specified port if we go back to that
port on the IP address we should be able
to refresh it and see our angular app
being served there now so that's how you
get started with front-end development
with coder but what I really want to
show you is how to wire that BS code
with some of the most advanced computing
hardware out there a tensor processing
unit or TPU is a piece of hardware
designed for large scale machine
learning problems they're used to train
AI models for things like Gmail Google
search Google Translate and they just
recently became available to the public
if you're looking to get into deep
learning a TPU is a lot more cost
effective and a lot more powerful than a
typical and Vidia GPU graphics card
let's start by going to the TP use tab
on compute engine TPS are not cheap
you'll definitely wanna make sure you
delete this when you're done using it
otherwise you'll be looking at about
$3,000 per month or 450 per hour but
that's actually very reasonable
considering how much computing power is
behind these things you can create your
TPU from the console but I actually find
it easier to do from the command-line so
we'll open up a new session here and
then we'll run see TPU up
and this is going to create a TPU node
as well as a virtual machine that we can
use to interact with that node and run
code it will also install tensor flow in
that VM so it takes care of some of the
setup for us you'll notice another VM
running in the VM instance list this
one's not going to have code server
installed so you'll need to go through
the exact same process that we went
through earlier I'm not going to cover
it in this video but if you're spinning
up multiple instances with code are
installed you'll definitely want to save
a disk image that you can reuse or a
docker container tensorflow is a Python
library and I already have it installed
on both of my virtual machines I'm not
going to cover the basics of machine
learning here but mostly want to show
you the performance difference from a
CPU to a TPU and we'll do that by
creating a problem here that uses a
neural network to process a lot of
synthetic or fake data the first thing
we'll do is create a data size of 2 to
the 18th power and then we'll use one
space to create an array with an
interval of values based on that size
then we'll go ahead and randomly shuffle
that array and then we'll format this
data so that it randomly follows the
shape of a sine wave so each point will
be an XY value and then we'll set up our
neural network to try to predict the Y
value of this data set so this is what
the data set looks like visually you can
see there's some random noise in here
and the neural network will try to fit a
line that best generalizes this data the
next thing I'm doing is separating this
data into a training set and a testing
set by simply slicing the array then
we'll define a function called get model
that uses Kerris to create a basic
neural network it starts with an input
layer that just takes our array and then
we'll split that into a layer with 200
nodes and then another layer with 80
nodes and then we'll output our final
prediction which should be the Y value
given the size of our data set this
model should take a very long time to
train the next thing we'll do is compile
the model we'll give it a standard
gradient descent optimizer and then
we'll be optimizing for the mean squared
error currently I'm writing this code on
our initial VM that just has the two CPU
cores it's running roughly one step in
the epoch per second there are a total
of 10 epics and 512 steps each which
means it should take about 90 minutes to
finish the training on this network
that's not too bad in the machine
learning world but let's see how much
faster this would be on a TPU I'm
switching over to the other VM that's
associated with the TPU and then I'm
adding some extra code here that will
hook up our existing model with the TPU
tensorflow has a variety of different
ways they can distribute data in this
case we'll use the TPU distribution
strategy then we'll fit the model using
these same parameters that we had before
and right away you'll see a huge
difference in performance each epoch
only takes about 15 seconds now so it
takes about 90 minutes on a CPU only
takes about 2.5 minutes in a TPU but
what's really awesome about all this is
that we now have access to the best
development tools like vs code in the
cloud well being able to scale up its
computing resources based on the demands
of the project or the size of the team
software is starting to become just as
good in the browser if not better than
it is installed on your local machine
coder is a perfect example of that and
something you'll definitely want to
check out I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and let me
know what you want to see next in the
comments thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]